[Applaudissements]
allo gens il y avait des bouchons
monstres sur le chemin de l'aéroport
j'ai raté mon avion
je déteste les aéroports à vous qui êtes
fous tu excelles textor
je sens en vous un petit esprit curieux
vous êtes un businessman regardez autour
de vous c'est mon havre
[Applaudissements]
et toi avez vous déjà tué quelqu'un
je vais vous demander de fermer les yeux
et de visualiser l'histoire que je vais
vous raconter dans les moindres détails
je suis désolé mais on ne s'est pas déjà
vu je ne crois pas une reçu désolé
c'était une totale perfection pourquoi
vous faisons parce que j'en viens au bi
quelle question
ma mensonge doit toujours être répétée
pour être cru contrairement à la vérité
[Rires]
les deux ans que je vous charge ce que
vous savez
cette porte
à quoi ça rime votre petit je croyais
que certains jeux mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez
la perfection est atteinte non pas
lorsqu'il n'y a plus rien à ajouter mais
lorsqu'il n'y a plus rien à retirer
[Musique]